okay so what i'm going to do here first
um
i'm going to say that for the sake of
simplicity okay and much like
here in front of the whiteboard okay
we're just thinking of motion
in terms of one dimension okay so this
is all one-dimensional
what that means is you can only go you
can only move
say back and forth or
left and right or up and down everything
is there's no
other way other place that i could move
in okay
and what we're going to say is
displacement we're going to call it x
because that is our um uh
letter of choice our pronounce when
we're talking about unknowns okay
now if we say okay i want to think about
the displacement of this mandarin
okay now um is there a stopwatch on them
i don't know if i can throw this i don't
know if this ceiling is high enough i
suspect it's not going to be
um but it's it's um sorry joe you might
go
without your no okay um jeffy i want you
to time
how long it takes up between the the um
the mandarin leaving my hand
and me catching it okay you ready we're
just okay on the count of three okay
one two three how long was that
um 93 milliseconds wow that was not very
long
19 milliseconds
milliseconds that doesn't sound right
because it wasn't that close to a second
i think that's 930 milliseconds isn't it
what's a millisecond isn't a millisecond
a thousandth
of a millisecond is less than a second
like it's the next stage down from one
second really well it is milliseconds
but i think it's 930 because didn't that
feel like about a second
yeah yeah it's about a second yeah
actually
millie is like wait it's a thousand okay
i'm telling you
i wanted it to be a little longer so let
me try and throw it a bit harder here
time for me again okay you ready
maybe if i maybe i got a bit lower okay
i'm ready sorry
oh no i said oh yeah okay all right so
you ready
okay this is gonna be dangerous okay on
the count of three one
two three okay how long was that
142 yeah that'll do okay let's let's
deal with it you know okay you can um
no i'm gonna hold on to it i might do
this
can i call it 15 is that okay it's just
an easier number okay
um let's call it um just so that we can
deal with like integers and stuff like
that
okay i'm thinking of time as t okay so i
should have said
is equal to t okay um
i'm gonna go in tenths of a second is
that okay
tenth of a second because that'll give
me integers okay so a tenth is like what
a deci a deca second okay
deca or deci which one is it decimal
decimate it's one in ten i think it's
desi
someone can surely someone can look this
up but anyway
if you like you could just forget what
you know it is and we can just call it
time minutes
okay so here's what we knew okay at time
zero
actually let's um let's draw i want to
just draw a really brief table
okay uh so i've got time and i've got
x as my displacement okay as i started
let's call my hand wherever my hand was
you know down below let's call that the
origin okay um that's where
displacement is equal to zero that's
where we begin
okay um now i think we actually know
let's go to 14 because
even is actually better 14 decky deci
seconds time units later okay it comes
back
right now uh when was it when was the
mandarin when was the mandarin highest
okay i assume it was halfway right based
on the fact that
when i throw it up it takes the same
amount of time to go up as does to go
down
okay so at seven don't get me into air
resistance okay
at seven now how far how far did it go
how i don't know how close you got to
the ceiling what do you want to call it
two meters well hold on a second i'm
like i'm like
one point seven eight i think i'm just
short of
six foot i think so so it went at least
twice as high as me right you can use
physics
three minutes should we call three three
figures
two
now by the way take note okay if i had
dropped the mandarin
okay it could have gone negative right
because we're thinking about
displacement
so that includes direction so it could
have gone down you know if it was some
it was like a mandarin made out of i
don't know
what's something dense like that little
i have to be
dense in the lid if i just drop lead it
will just hit the ground but if it was
like
you know the density of a black hole you
can just like go through the ground
like that so it could go negative okay
in some situation
okay now this this
i i could have more information right in
terms like what happens in between here
what happens in between here we could
have taken a physics
sort of approach to it that's what we've
done like observe it right
but now i want to enter the realm of the
mathematician because this is actually
enough for us
this is enough okay because if you think
about this
this is a displacement x is a function
of time
okay so you can write it like this
so the question is what kind of function
is it
and mathematically it's not doesn't take
that much imagination to think
well what kind of shape was it went up
uh and it was it was fastest when i when
i
released it and then at the top it
slowed down and then it came back
so the shape it draws out is a parabola
right
except it's sort of a parabola sort of
not because just goes up
and down right so in terms of motion
it's just on one dimension but if you
think about time
all right so let's draw this string then
shall we
now this is confusing because x is up
there
x is our vertical axis okay now that
maybe
makes sense for us because we're
actually thinking about up and downs
that that's okay
but later on um x might be left or right
um or back and forth or whatever
and it will always be this vertical axis
okay so there's a bit of a shift right
away
okay now we said uh it goes
up and then it hits three
okay and then it comes back down
and the whole journey took um 14 time
units
so i've got uh seven
in the in the middle there okay now this
is a section of a parabola
okay and that because we're just
imagining this it doesn't have to be
real perfectly accurate
because it's true because of like if
you're a physicist right you'd have to
worry about the fact that this part
and this part would not be exactly equal
because there's like other factors
involved okay
but as a mathematician i can be like i'm
just going to call them equal
make it a perfectly symmetrical object
okay what is its equation
what is its equation
i want x equals something okay i've got
intercepts
right i've got an internet zero and one
at fourteen okay so how would i start to
write out my rating
okay now that's that'll give me the
roots in the right spot
the zero and the 14 okay but there's
something else i haven't taken into
account
namely how high it went right so how do
i factor in the fact
the point that this is three sorry seven
three how do i do this
so i wanna test that well okay when t
equals
seven right i want it to equal three
okay what happens with this equation
well at the moment
x will equal seven uh times
seven minus fourteen hmm
minus 49 something has gone wrong what's
going wrong
a couple of a few things have gone wrong
hold on a second this thing
has the right roots it's got zero and
fourteen okay so it's upside down
okay because that makes sense this thing
is concave
up right so this is the wrong kind of
parabola right how should i fix that
slap a minor sign on it okay good
now what effect does that have here
minus sign
that's positive i still don't have
exactly what i want so how am i going to
adjust it
it's it's 49 which um you know i'd like
to think that i have a good arm but it's
not that good so
i need to adjust that i need to ratchet
that down okay so how am i going to
adjust this original equation
such that this becomes 3 not 49.
i could subtract 46
but that would give me some problems
right because when you have a graph
and you um subtract a constant from it
what effect does that have on the graph
it it moves it up and down so if i just
move it 46 units down
okay the roots are also going to move
okay so a constant unfortunately
will not do okay now take another step
back let's just imagine what is this
equation what does it look like
well we've said it's 49th so it looks
like this
yeah so in terms of shape
it's exactly right but it's off not by
position but by
scale right it's just too it's too tall
okay so how do i squash it down
if you had a line and you wanted to make
it smaller and greater what would you do
it's about the coefficient isn't it
right like i i'm
worried this thing is too steep okay
this is actually like this
and i want it to just be that right so
therefore
i still want these intercepts to stay
put so i want to multiply it by i'll put
this at the front
minus 3 on 49.
okay can you see what that's going to do
it's gonna
divide that number by 49 and then
multiply by three which will land it
exactly where i wanted it
okay so now i've got these values right
okay